you think will ferrell would be
technically savvy
or maybe you wouldn't think he would be
technically savvy
i got all walks of life who somehow can
set up a zoom
chat but not will ferrell actor comedian
former saturday night live cast member
all around good guy
you can see us but we can't see you
that's creepy will
yep that's the way i do all my zooms
oh no my my my computer's working just
fine
why can't i see you i don't know i uh
as i as i mentioned before uh
well in an email that that my my zoom
uh ratio is 50 50. so a lot of times
this happens i don't know why
do you you have kids can't the boys come
in and figure this out
they're still sleeping oh okay yeah what
about your wife
she's still sleeping everyone's still
sleeping
are you nude uh no no no
no i i have a a nice shirt on i
oh no i actually put gel in my hair
um i was ready to go done
and now it's just an auditory yeah
wait so dan is this have you been is
this a simulcast
technically yeah yeah yeah it has been
since you've known us
but this is even more of a simulcast
yeah it would be
it would be helpful if we could see you
like we could get a glimpse into your
life
and then maybe you could give us a
little tour of your man cave or wherever
you are
right right right like that'd be better
for my failure
it would have been it would have been
great yeah
but here we are i know
you know fritz fritzi has his uh emmys
prominently displayed behind him
yeah haven't spent a lot of money for
those yeah do you have any emmys
i just i finally got an emmy i have one
emmy
that's for am i supposed to guess as a
producer on succession
yes you could please yes thank you is it
succession
no uh as a producer on the
live sitcom we did uh all in the family
and the jeffersons with uh jimmy kimmel
oh
and you got an emmy for that i got yeah
which is
how nice is that what what other awards
do you have for acting in there i mean
you don't have the big one
yet
[Laughter]
i don't have uh i don't have
any awards for acting
i've got it i've got a couple amazing i
have three
guys choice awards when that used to
exist
uh i've got some espys
once again not for acting um i the the
most prestigious award i have
uh is a uh the mark twain award for
uh american comedy that's a big deal
that's a big deal right how how nervous
were you that night that's in dc
and that's it that's where your your um
constituents your fellow comedians come
forward and say nice things about you
say nice things you you sit up in a like
a royal box
situation yeah and uh
and then you have to come down and make
a speech yourself with your your
your family watching and in front of a
thousand people so it's a
it's a pretty a pretty uh heady thing
but it was uh
one of the highlights yeah that's a big
deal i saw uh dave chappelle
uh when he got that and uh
it looked like it was pretty pretty big
night for everybody i was
i was a little disappointed because i
was under the impression when i got mine
that they weren't going to give any more
help
they were like we're
we we're good yeah you know we've yeah
we've exhausted the humor
exactly yeah we're done what are your
plans today
like when you get done with this what
will you do
i'm gonna well i'm gonna get the it guy
out that's for sure
um they don't have to do a deep cleaning
um what what let's see i might go
uh uh i might go exercise
uh i'll probably have to go walk the
dogs
i saw where you were like the paparazzi
just waits for you to come out of your
house don't they there is a
one one area where they hang out yeah up
on mulholland
and then they just wait for you
they wait four people yes not
necessarily me but
but other famous people yes well like
what other famous people
i don't know i ran i ran in my wife and
i ran into uh
uh sasha baron cohen and i isla fisher
oh yeah one day okay and then
and then that that's been it so
well what do you talk about do you like
is it you know each other
they they they were on they were on
bicycles and uh
they stopped and they said oh hey it's
you guys and we said oh hey it's you
guys and then they
asked us about our uh sheepdog cosmo
that we were walking and um
where did we where did we get a dog like
that and we explained
and they then said we might email you
guys because
maybe we'll get a sheep dog and that's
that's the level of conversation that's
happening in the hollywood hills
is it assumed that famous people know
famous people like everybody knows
everybody
yeah it's assumed it's also uh but
there's also a strange um
uh i i wouldn't call it an immediate
uh intimacy between famous people but
when famous people see famous people
they're like hey
how are you yeah i like you
yeah you too how you been good where um
i think other prominent people in other
lines of work
wouldn't stop you know the ceo of boeing
wouldn't stop uh
the you know head of
gm and go hey man
i saw you on the cover of corporate
weekly you lost some weight i like what
you do over there
so it's uh i don't know it's a strange
uh you feel like you you should
you should say hello and if you don't
it's rude and you know
things like that he's will ferrell actor
comedian former saturday night live cast
member and not an i.t guy
joining us on the program are you
what are you watching anything good
well i've been watching along with it
sounds like the rest of america uh
last dance what do you think
well i i'm i'm i'm i'm not the most
objective audience only because uh i
uh any any s i'll enjoy anything like
that just as a sports fan just to see
the
you know the history and to remind
yourself all right that's that happened
and
but uh i'm i'm enjoying it thoroughly
but you're a laker fan
yeah do you acknowledge though the
greatness of jordan and the bulls
of course okay yeah did you ever go out
and
i'm trying to think back what were you
doing in the 90s
uh well i was just trying to remember if
i actually got to see jordan play
yeah um in an actual game i
i saw him play i saw him play twice
in the strangest of circumstances i saw
him
as a sophomore at when he was a
sophomore
at uh carolina play because i was a
i was a camper at the dean smith
basketball camp in
university of north carolina the only
kid
from from california probably one of the
few kids from out of state
and uh and they did a pickup uh they did
a pickup scrimmage between uh
some alumni and the current uh team and
and uh
and michael jordan we watched michael
jordan play wait how did you end up at
dean
smith's basketball camp coming from
california
uh i just uh i was just a weird kid
dan well your parents trying to get no
no we're not okay no uh no oh yeah they
were trying to get me
away from uh uh no all my family's from
north carolina
so my dad went to chapel hill and uh we
thought it would be uh
oh that's good it'd be fun to go to
basketball camp uh
even though uh like i said i was the
only kid from california and most of the
campers go with their own team
uh so every kid had like four or five
buddies
except for me so i lie in my dorm room
going
only four more nights only four more
nights you can do it did you ever meet
jordan
i met him you know what i met him while
we were uh
shooting i think i think we were
shooting bewitched
at culver studios
and they said jordan's next door
shooting a hanes underwear commercial
so he wasn't in his underwear but uh
yeah madam
that's the one time i met him you would
have been great in a hanes underwear
i know right thank you like put you in
some medium underwear and let you yeah
i mean that's right in your wheelhouse
i'm not
you're gonna move some product i'm a
little bit past the medium i probably
have to go
xl yeah but still
yeah i i'm if haynes is listening i'm
ready
for sure yeah how did you end up in the
uh
seattle seahawks video chat
oh that was all pete that was pete
carroll who had texted me we were
texting a little bit during the draft
because he had said that i was a uh
i was a draft clue zoolander was a draft
glue
and did i have any other ideas to send
him wait what do you mean draft clue
i don't know he didn't ever explain it
so i go what does it have to can i can
send you clues i i
assumed he meant uh you know
self-referential clues
uh things from movies i'd done et cetera
and i said what do do the clues have to
correlate to anything he's like no
doesn't matter so i don't know if they
just post things to try to throw their
fans off as to who they might be
drafting
and then he said hey i'm going to do
this video chat with yeah then
then the next day he was uh like you
want to you want to crash our thing
and you were greg olsen i was greg olson
the uh
incoming tight end and he let himself go
like a poor former carolina panther yeah
he did not look in game shape
i don't think he thinks there's going to
be a season so he's let himself go
yeah uh can you
do you think there's gonna be a comedy
made off of
this you know quarantine
yeah it's a really good question i don't
know uh i don't know if
if you're anything that's set in
in contemporary uh times is it
does it beg to have to uh address what's
going on
or are people going to want to watch
things where
we're not reminded of this i i'm not
quite sure it's a
it's a really good question um got a
little serious there on me didn't you
yeah
sorry yeah sorry what are you doing
don't don't do it well i was wondering
if you have a relationship that starts
because of quarantine and then you're
stuck
together you know the first day there's
definitely going to be a romantic comedy
in which
uh people
i think i really love her oh she's super
special
guess what i can't see her for six
months but you you've never been in a
rom-com with kate hudson like every
other
actor male actor has right you're due
for a kate hudson romka
i'm i am due for a classic
kate hudson matthew mcconaughey rom-com
yes you'll be the wacky neighbor there
no i'm going to be a tough uh sweet
talking
corporate lawyer
you don't like that yeah well i wish i
could have seen you
it would have been really really good
for me in my career
guys you look great i loved
watching all the danettes watch me but
you're not you just have to look into
the camera
and uh and my my
it's just a void you're just looking at
a void why
rank how my guys look so start with
fritzy what do you make of his
setup that he's got there fritz let's
see
it some beautiful uh burnished hardwood
uh walls there i can't quite see what
that is that a
child's uh uh piece of artwork behind me
it is it
definitely is oh there we go that now
we're up and then it looks like uh
is that a a sports illustrated cover of
uh
mcmahon behind
great what do you think of mclovin's set
up there in brooklyn
mclaughlin i got can you go full frame
here i can't quite see oh okay
uh a lot of sunlight coming in you get a
lot of light in that room
i do it's uh is that the wrong way here
in brooklyn when you get depressed you
go into that room
yeah but it's a greenhouse it's very hot
in here
that's the entire apartment there yeah
it is
very minimal uh seton set up at his crib
seton let's see what you have there i i
love the uh
the washburn guitar there behind you
oh that's your that's your beat
laboratory
the synth yeah yeah that's right yeah
yeah yeah
yeah we're making beats here for sure
you you and the family record you have a
little family band you record
a lot of tracks or yeah yeah we got
that's my son's guitar
right over there so uh he also plays the
piano so next to the drink cart
right yeah we put it right up there
yeah right by the bar like a drink cart
and then you got paulie here in the man
cave with me oh paulie's in the man cave
so
yeah there's that's it yeah that's every
day that's every day
uh well i i'm glad you're you're doing
well you've never looked better
and uh thanks guys hopefully we'll get a
chance to see you one day
i you know i think this really inspires
me i want to do an in
studio appearance at some point when
this all loosens up
where i just wear a black tarp over my
head
just like you're giving the appearance
now you have a screen that is
it'll be a in studio
uh zoom-like appearance i i'm gonna look
forward to that
and uh and and once again i i swear to
god if you pull the tape off that if
there's tape on that
camera and
if i find out there was tape on i mean
i'm looking at it no it's your
it's your computer
i don't know if your camera's not
working or you put black tape on the on
your
on the computer now if you did it's a
great bit and i'll applaud you
it's a commodore pc are they still good
okay well maybe time for an upgrade but
i yeah
i'm going to say i'm going to say
goodbye and if i see you
pull that piece off pull that tape off
wouldn't that be the best
it would be i would applaud you but it's
like it's like the time you guys thought
i was gonna come out and clown makeup
or whatever like when i took an hour and
a half to get ready for your guy's show
in l.a
yeah yeah you were in a sweatsuit you
i went why did it take an hour and a
half to put that together
right i don't know
uh you know what good luck the rest of
your busy day uh
tell uh sasha baron cohen that i say
hello and the paparazzi as well
okay that's will ferrell right there he
took part in uh covet is no joke a
comedy fundraiser uh this past friday
and
we almost got to see what that all
looked like there